this is Startalk hello this is Startalk
Allstars edition I'm your all-star host
this evening Carolyn Porco is my name
and I'm a planetary scientist and the
leader of the imaging science team on
the Cassini mission which is as we speak
in orbit around Saturn my co-host today
is chuck nice Thank You Chuck for being
here thank you and my guest today is
Chris McKay from the Ames Research
Center in the Bay Area he's
astrobiologist
extraordinaire chris spends his time
scouring the deserts of earth from
antarctica to siberia namibia Sahara
trying to understand those places on the
earth that might be like Mars in their
environment and wondering how life can
thrive there he's been involved in
conjuring what kind of human mission
back to Mars might be like this is a
mission that would be piloted by by
humans he's involved in that and I've
invited him here today because he is my
cohort for the last 11 years in trying
to get people to pay attention to what
we have found with the Cassini mission
at on Enceladus which is a small moon in
the Saturn system no bigger across the
England
and why this small moon presents to us
the most promising environment in the
solar system to actually search for life
for evidence of prebiotic chemistry so
welcome Chris Thank You Carolyn pleasure
to be here talking with you yes so we've
gathered your cosmic queries about
Enceladus and astrobiology from various
social media that's right Chuck have you
have done that that's exactly what we
have done and we have questions with the
Facebook and Twitter and you name it
whether it's star talk dotnet it does
make a difference we take them and they
all want to know about in some of this
add more you know astrobiology and more
you know people see your name and you
know some people just want to know about
Cassini and some people want to know
about Saturn and so I know that we're
kind of focused on Enceladus but
you know when you you say when when
people who who follow us when we say
Carolyn Porco they immediately think
Saturn because Neil calls you Madame
Saturn Madame Saturn for the rest of my
life I'll be madam Saturn if I write it
could be it could be worth a lot wicker
viewers so let's take our first you know
we always like to have a patreon for
those of you who are interested in
supporting us on patreon by doing so you
get to do cool things like you get
invited to parties that we might throw
or you can submit a question for our
cosmic queries and we will make sure
that we read it because you gave us
money that's a basic transaction right
right that's a basic life transaction
you gave us money and now we're going to
do something for you so this is from
Luna McIntyre who says do you think
there are parallels that can be inferred
by whatever is found with the Europa
mission since the liquid oceans on both
moons I suppose both moons she means
Enceladus and Europa seems to be due to
tidal heating so are there any first of
all is that the case I mean are both
moons their oceans created by tidal
heating and are there any parallels that
we can draw or infer from the
similarities between Europa and
Enceladus there are a tremendous amount
of parallels that we can draw they are
in fact both heated by this mechanism of
tidal flexure which is why they have
oceans within them and both of them have
oceans and I would say it doesn t have
been nearly a dozen years now exploring
up close and personal Enceladus with the
Cassini mission and with us an amazing
suite of 12 investigations on the
orbiter that have been brought to bear
over the course of a dozen years and we
know a tremendous amount about Enceladus
really far more knowledge about
Enceladus at this point
than we do about Europa but I'll turn
this over to Chris because Chris also
has a lot to say about this topic so
what do you have to say well to me the
most interesting comparison between
Enceladus and Europa would be comparing
the type of life we might find in both
of them imagine some time in the future
when we find life on its eldest we find
life on your own are they the same life
do they represent a common origin or do
that or did life start independently on
both of these water worlds or did life
start a lot of not the other so I'm
always focused on the biology questions
and a comparison between worlds is the
most interesting possibility in terms of
what kind of questions you can ask about
biology and compare these two water
worlds and then of course we want to
compare them to earth as well is a
biology on Europa if there is any and
the biology on Enceladus if there is any
compare to the biology we have here on
earth that's the ultimate question for
astrobiology yeah and and let me let me
just remind people why why we've gone so
googoo gaga over Enceladus and that is
because we found that it has a hundred
and one tall geysers that are erupting
from its south polar terrain which is an
area if you were to scale and sell it us
up to the size of the earth it would be
like the latitude of Tierra del Fuego
and everything south well or if you were
biased towards the northern hemisphere
would be like Edinburgh Scotland and
everything north well so imagine having
a hundred and one enormous geysers
erupting from the terrain that's that
large and once we found with Cassini
these geysers and we knew that they were
the particles that we see in our images
were accompanied by vapour and they
formed this enormous plume that when
ultimately tens of thousands of
kilometres into orbit around Saturn
we took a Seanie and we went barreling
through it right we went barreling
through it time and time and time again
and we've been able to collect material
and measure the contents of the vapor
measure the contents of the particles
measure the characteristics of the
particles how big they are how their
size is distributed above the surface
and all this information has finally
told us where we are right now we know
we have a global ocean under about 35
kilometers worth of ice it's salty it's
it's salty like the earth sauce is salty
and it has organic materials so it's got
all the formal requirements of what in
the NASA world and that's a universe we
call a habitable zone and that ocean is
accessible now what we have to do is fly
through it again with the proper
instruments right better than we have on
Cassini to measure measure it at us with
a greater precision and a start asking
really interesting astrobiological
questions Chris what are some of the
things we could do if we had a mission
that went back to Enceladus with proper
instrumentation what what kinds of
questions do we really want to know well
I think you you said it well Carolyn we
already know it's habitable we already
know it has organic material you already
know it has liquid water we know that
that liquid water is habitable so that
the follow-on questions really go right
to the biology done this habitable
environment is it an Avenue does it have
life and then the challenge is how do we
search for life well we can search for
life using molecules and tools that we
develop for characterizing Earth life
but it'd be nice to also have a
capability or detective life if it's not
everyone so then the question becomes
how do we tech life that similar to
earth lives in water made of carbon but
is not directly related to us doesn't
have our DNA and I think the answer to
that is to search for amino acid and
search for their handedness and see if
there is a enrichment of heavy complex
amino acids in the plume of Enceladus
and then to see if those amino acids all
have the same handedness which is a
clear signature of biological
selectivity well so when you you know
from an astro biological standpoint what
would be
what would be more desirable to analyze
these things or analyze these components
flying through these plumes or capturing
the water and bringing it back good
question
that's a very very good question there
is there are people out there groups of
people one group I know of that are
looking at the possibility of a sample
return it's not a trivial thing to do
because there's a lot of concern if you
bring a sample back to earth you don't
want to have an in dramatist rain
scenario where you can contaminate yes
your it so you know that has to be done
carefully but those Earthlings were
really something special until they
bought that Dettol Enceladus water
really that was the beginning of the end
you know the instruments that we have on
earth are far more sophisticated than
the ones that we could carry on a
spacecraft so so Chris in fact has been
a big proponent of a sample return
mission yeah but but as Carolyn points
out one has to be extremely careful in
bringing back a sample from an
environment that we think could have
life in it and that environment is very
similar to Earth's oceans we've never
done that before we've brought back
samples before but we've never brought
back a sample from a habitable
environment so this is a new challenge
and we have to proceed extremely
carefully with it so I think
realistically the next missions to
Enceladus will not be sample return they
will investigate the plume and catch you
following up on Cassini but they will be
designed to search for life unlike kasim
Cassini did a fabulous job it was a
wonderful an unexpected find and its
ability investigated surprised all of us
and what has told us also surprised all
of us now we're back with the mission
that's based on what we know and search
for life in the plume and then meanwhile
think about how we bring a sample back
safe because ultimately we have to do
that yeah I wanted can I just make a
plug for Cassini because there's chris
said the instruments on Cassini that
were really I mean the cameras you know
can take a picture of anything but the
instruments that told us about the
chemist
three were not designed to investigate a
plume of material that was as tenuous as
that which is coming off the South Pole
of Enceladus they were designed to
measure the atmosphere of Titan for
example okay which is much more hefty so
it just it was a beautiful demonstration
of how important it is to first of all
be in orbit and kind of take up
residence in a planetary system so you
have the leisure of discovering
something and then going back to
investigate it again and again and
making changes in your approach right
and that's what we did with Cassini but
I want to add just one more thing about
Enceladus which fascinates me ninety to
ninety four percent of the stuff that's
being erupted from the South Pole of
Enceladus the particles not the vapor
but the particles comes back down in the
surface it snows back down to the
surface so if there are microbes in the
ocean of Enceladus that are being you
know shot out they are it's snowing
microbes at the South Pole of Enceladus
so I think another thing we want to do
is we want to go sample those particles
and see if there are microbes in it
that's what I get really excited about
that's pretty cool I it doesn't get any
cooler than that that's like that that's
the Holy Grail that's pretty fun now and
what do you do when you do that is that
is that putting instrumentation down on
the surface well this is very
interesting you know we've all been
discussing this we're discussing how you
might actually do this and it just
occurred to me recently you don't need
to land on the surface okay all you need
to do is really get into orbit around
Enceladus and the speed with which you
pick up these particles would be gentle
enough that you would not destroy part
of microbes that were in the ice
particles and that's what we want we'd
love to be able to take a look at them
now whether or not we have the
instrumentation now to do it is a
question maybe Chris do you know
something about this the the
capabilities of microscopic imagers to
do this sort of things as you point out
you don't have a heritage in planetary
missions or searching for life we
haven't done that since Viking 1976 but
meanwhile NASA
and other organizations have been
developing technologies for studying
life on earth there's been satellites in
Earth orbit that have looked at biology
there's technologies on the space
station and these life sciences
technology can be applied to the search
for life and be made suitable for
planetary missions light and I insist
technology yeah what do you what do you
mean by life sciences - that sounds
oddly like uh like a life coach not that
what I mean is life is not a lifestyle a
lifestyle like what if the life science
is good well we can we can think of two
different jobs that we might do in space
one is take life from Earth right and
study it in space that's called life
science okay
search for life on other worlds like two
texts they're both centered on light but
in one case you're taking like with you
is studying it the other case you're
going somewhere and seeing if there's
life there but for example a fluorescent
microscope would be handy in both cases
well there's not been the development of
such a microscope for planetary but
there has been for life sciences people
have taken these kind of instrumentation
into orbit the study organisms that
they've carried with them to investigate
the response of these organisms to the
space environment huh I can take that
technology and repurpose it to searching
for life in the plume of himself oh god
it's so exciting I can barely stand it
that that is really it's it's like there
it's waiting for us to go back super
cool super cool okay let's go on to
another question we have a little bit of
time left in the segment so let's grab
another question from Nicole coming to
us from Twitter at Kate girl is her name
and she's talking with respect to
astrobiology what role if any would the
study of planetary atmospheres and
remote sensing have on the search for
extraterrestrial life so is there
anything that we can glean just from
looking at a planet that we know does
not have life on it and look at the
planet's atmosphere and I'll go one step
further and say even the planets
landscape from from the standpoint of
astrobiology and find out about life or
the or extraterrestrial life on that
planet okay so I think Chris this is one
for you did you
did you get that yes I got it and this
is a really good question it's a really
good question and it has implications
right now on searching for life on a
other world and other stars exoplanets
and also searching for life on Titan
which is a world that does have an
atmosphere and we can character and the
thought is that planet that life does
affect the planet and its atmosphere
here you had on earth the oxygen in our
atmosphere was clearly produced by
biology if we see oxygen in the
atmosphere of an exoplanet I would take
that as pretty compelling evidence that
there is life on that planet making that
oxygen we have by that same logic you
can't apply that logic to Enceladus it
doesn't have a nap nor does Europa but
Titan done it's a very different
atmosphere than Earth would have very
different life but we can take the same
logic if there was life on type how
would it change the app and the
conclusion seems to be it would be
depleting hydrogen so imagine a mission
that goes to Titan and searches or a
depletion of hydrogen and uses that as a
bio signature the same way that the
presence of oxygen in an atmosphere is
used as a bio signature okay questioner
Chris we have to we have to sorry we
have to take a short break now we'll
come back to what you're saying because
it's really exciting and we'll take more
of the cosmic queries from our audience
when Startalk returns
welcome back to star talk radio
all-stars edition I'm your all-star host
Carolyn Porco and joining me in the
studio is Chuck Knight yeah for being
here such a pleasure and read the light
Carolina hello thank you and our special
guest is Chris McKay planetary
scientists and astrobiologists
extraordinaire at NASA and he was in the
middle of giving us an argument about
you might look at on a planet or a moon
that had an atmosphere here and how that
would determine life and you were
talking about well if you were to look
at an atmosphere and see oxygen you
would know or you would be able to and
only in wrongly indicate that hey
something created that something
biological created that so can you go on
from there well the point was this is
very powerful technique because it can
be done remotely and the questioner
indicated that and this is true it this
is the only way we could detect life
currently around planets around other
stars there's some question now I would
just be maybe a devil's advocate here
and say that you could never really know
to a 100% confidence that that kind of a
bio signature would give you would mean
life but it would be a strong indicator
I think that's right
yeah would certainly be very excited
yeah earth-like planet around a sun-like
star and find high level of oxygen in
the atmosphere of that plan yeah
technically there's other ways but it
would be a strong indication of life
yeah I know it's I know people in that
community who think that the only way
you'd really know if we had life would
be the interception of a signal from an
extraterrestrial intelligence that's
like the only thing that would really
give you a hundred percent confidence
but but it would be it would be a
red-letter day if we found an exoplanet
with that's fantastic that's that's good
well Nicole thank you for such a very
well-thought-out question let us move on
and ask a question from Doug dumphy who
wants to know what the next likely
mission to Enceladus
what do you hope it is capable to do
beyond Cassini hashtag CQ Enceladus
which is our hashtag I don't know why I
read that well you're just you're just
being just being thorough being peril
right little too thorough I think we
just said that but we can say it again
yes we did we did kind of get into that
but go ahead I'm just going to say
Cassini has done a bang-up job
unexpectedly because if one of us Chris
said I think we didn't really we
suspected Enceladus might have geysers
but we didn't expect that it would they
would be they would look the way they do
and be as vigorous and phenomenon as it
has been it's just been an explorer's
dream come true and so what we want to
do next is go back with instrumentation
that is far better than that which was
carried by Cassini look at the chemical
constituents to a finer level of detail
and look at abundances of compounds look
at as Chris mentioned the handedness of
compounds because you know earthly life
prefers a particular type of molecule to
another and if we see that same kind of
signature on another planet that might
also indicate a process like life that
has singled that particular type of
molecule out so those are the kinds of
things we would look for and like I said
one of my favorites is actually to grab
and look at an image microbes so that's
the kind of things we're talking about
going back to Enceladus nice but the the
key is we are going back is that well no
not what what do you read oh I'm sure
that well there's a bunch of us that are
really pressing for it and we have the
opportunity there's we now can submit to
NASA what are called new frontiers
proposals so this is proposals for like
a big chunk of money something like 850
million dollars but that doesn't mean
we'll get selected there are people who
want to go to Venus people who want to
go return a sample from a comet there's
lots of color let me ask you that
something and this is this is just part
of our conversation and I think it's
terrible that we have to kind of
make choice choices like this it'd be
Sophie's choices where you know it's
like well should we go to Venus or
should we go to Mars or should we go
back to and so it's like we should be
doing all of this to be honest I mean
let's let's be let's be very square we
should be doing all of this so how do
you prioritize which missions should
take place and when is there a
particular protocol that should be in
place to determine maybe this mission is
important but it's more important if we
go now
maybe this mission is important but it
really won't be important until you know
2030 so how do you go about making the
case for you know getting these limited
funds which shouldn't be limited as far
as I'm concerned well they are limited
in Chris I'll let you deal with this
you're the guy who works at NASA sure
sure but I tell you my way of
prioritizing me because I have to
prioritize my time also what do I work
on all the planets are interesting I
prioritize it based on what's going to
tell us the most about biology now and I
think the clear winner is Enceladus so I
would answer are we going themselves yes
because it's clearly a place where we
can learn the most about possibility of
life right now other worlds are
interesting too but Enceladus is ready
for investigation their samples there as
Carolyn said it's a habitable
environment samples come out into space
if the low-hanging fruit it's what we
ought to do first in my opinion yeah
it's not clear it's not clear it's going
to happen but a Chris and I that's why
we're cohorts and this together we're
trying to keep and sell it as up front
and center in the minds of people
because it it is like you said it's it
we're ready we're ready now we know
enough to go back and do the job right
good stuff let's move on and take
another question this one a little bit
more broad from Kabira mal Malhotra I'm
terrible Carolyn you will know the more
you do this people like to end Chris you
will know because I'm sure you will
return as a guess
people send me their names and you have
no idea how to pronounce and I butcher
their names like you can't believe and I
think that they're doing it on purpose
now I I really do I think people are
just sending me made-up names just just
to see me squirm and struggle and
because but anyway they're listening
this is true okay exactly so this is I
hope I'm saying Kabir Malhotra Malhotra
okay assuming the universe is infinite
that's a big assumption right there I
mean is the universe infinite because I
really don't think it is but anyway
let's not that's just not I'm not
answering these questions you are how
long will it take to produce an exact
copy of Earth I don't think he means
exact copy of Earth but an earth-like
planet just you know basically our earth
so an exact copy is ridiculous because
you know that's ridiculous to say an
exact copy of birth that's just never
going to happen and by the way the earth
is changing all the time
so what would that exact copy be right
you know because on earth that we live
on today is not the earth that was here
four million years ago that's right it's
a completely different planet now so but
how long would it take to produce an
earth planet well I'm going to turn this
around because that's a very difficult
answer so I'm going to turn it around to
something that's possible to answer I
like the way you work Kepler results of
how many exoplanets there are and what
characteristics they are
this is Kepler with follow-on
earth-based observations from telescopes
like heck have indicated something like
25 percent I hope I get this right 25
percent of the planetary candidates that
they find in the habitable zone of their
star are earth sized okay I think that's
right and then some fraction of those
would be earth-like and you could call
it you know earth twin or
twin right and I don't know someone took
a reasonable guess maybe let's say 20% I
you know it's common nothing on our
planet is is unusual that is that's what
we've been able to glean about the
universe is you know what we have here
is probably lots of other places right
so 25% of the planetary candidates in
the habitable zone alike are sized let's
say 20% of those are earth-like which
means like the earth ok the copy and and
when you go through all the numbers the
last time I heard this which is probably
six months or a year ago the number came
out to something like five billion four
billion earth-like planets in our galaxy
oh my death right now here right now
right Chris do I got that right the gist
of the argument is certainly correct
there are going to be in our own galaxy
a lot of earth-like planets we've got to
look we know that there's lots of
planets out there and some of them would
be like earth we don't need an infinite
universe our own galaxy in fact our own
stellar neighborhood probably has lots
of lots and lots of Perth like planets
arbitrarily closely similar to earth the
more we want to look the more we can
find ones that are as close to Earth as
we want to be really we might have a lot
of community work ahead of us yeah yeah
and Wow so I mean that's that's pretty
unnerving when you think about it
because now I'm nervous it's it's it's
it's just incredible scientific
sightings what I say unnerving I mean in
a in a good say in a good sense it is
really that exciting that that it's
unnerving is you know it's it's it's
shocking is what it is it's shocking so
now let me ask the both of you this with
that in mind does it necessarily
increase the likelihood of there being
intelligent life on one of those planets
since we pretty much developed on this
planet it doesn't increase the
likelihood or does it does it not I mean
are those two things related in any way
scientifically or I mean you know look
we have we have a statistic of one right
now on an earth-like
one civilization has developed to the
point where we call ourselves
intelligent and we are capable of
communicating across space so you know
if it happened once it's likely to
happen again how how likely is it I
don't know I guess that's a guess but I
I'm an optimist I think that probably
it's it's happened many times Chris do
you want to take a guess what do you
think you're an optimist I know I am as
well and I I think it's useful to divide
the question into two steps one is the
distribution of life and then secondly
the distribution of intelligent life
certainly we think that life should be
widespread whether some of those life
forms develop intelligence is a more
deeper question but I can be an optimist
student so I think we're going to find
the universe just full of life and that
many but not all of those life-bearing
planets have developed themselves gotcha
that doesn't mean that they're like on
their way to get us right now it's the
distances are I mean are prohibitive
yeah when you say a star is twelve
thousand light-years away that we're
talking that's the time it takes light
right the fastest thing we have to get
here it would take us far far longer
than that so yes I mean the the
realistically these the life could exist
there but our being able to get to that
life is very unlikely
well eventually I suppose we could put
put some robotic spacecraft on a course
for OnStar and maybe it makes sense yes
robot dummynet so so that brings me to
another question from both of you okay
especially you Chris being a
astrobiologists is it more important to
have a first contact from one of us
making contact with intelligent life or
from an emissary that we have created
I II a robot or Android or you know some
representation of human life whether
it's a computer or what have you and you
know of course that probably will make
more sense because we can send that
thing out and just let it go we don't
have to feed it we don't have to worry
about it dying and
it's not going to and complain
like I'm lonely and I miss my family and
so yeah so I mean what is that is that
most likely how we're going to make our
first content you know we might have
made a first contact already you know I
mean we have our our signals sent out
what did Dan wear timer just saying he
said 70 years ago right 70 something
like that but you know so so we won't
know that's the thing about this whole
thing is the distances are so usually we
won't know if we've made a contact with
another civilization until we hear back
from them doctor okay interesting
yes okay so we have just limited time so
we're going to wrap this up for this
segment we'll take a short break and
when we come back we're going to
entertain more of you our listeners
cosmic queries when Startalk returns
hello again and welcome back to star
talk radio all stars edition I am your
all-star host Carolyn Porco and joining
me in the studio is my my fabulous
wonderful dynamic co-host Chuck nice
thank you thank you a moment I started
to look around the scene as well else
was here and and we have is our special
guest we have Chris McKay who's an
astrobiologist from NASA Ames Research
Center in the Bay Area we've been
talking about the search for life in the
solar system there isn't a topic that's
more exciting than that and we're going
to now discuss what kind of life we
might find on a place like Enceladus and
how might it be different than the life
we have here on earth this is a really
tantalizing question because I think
most people would agree it would really
be far more interesting to find life
that was entirely different from the
life we have here biochemically
metabolically all those things because
then we'd have a point of comparison
that we could make and that would
give us insights into how life developed
one way on one planet and one way on the
other so Chris why don't you weigh in on
this for us because I'm sure this is
something that you thought quite a lot
of sure normally when we talk about
different life we're thinking something
goes off exotic like maybe silicon-based
life or something that's not what we're
going to find on Enceladus Kinsella this
is a world with water and carbon life
thick there will be big heart just like
us but it might still be profoundly
different how that's carbon and water
arranges to form biochemistry could be
very different on itself so for example
DNA which we use to store information
may not be the same molecule you thought
on Enceladus the store information the
proteins on Enceladus may be made out of
amino acids just like the proteins on
earth but they may be made out of
different amino acid or the chirality
the antigen of those amino acids might
be opposite so there's many ways that
life Enceladus could be very very
different than life on Earth it would be
very interesting to do that comparison
now for us to do that I'm guessing that
that's going to be pretty hard to do
with the kind of stuff we're talking
about that might be done on the very
next mission to Enceladus I'm going to
guess that in order to do that we really
got to bring samples back to earth I do
you agree with that - really surely I
think oh go ahead I think we could go a
long way with instruments that we send
there yes for example we search for
amino acids and we find that the plume
of Enceladus has amino acids complex one
and they're all let's say right hand is
the opposite of first life then we've
learned all the enormous amount about
life on themselves and we've determined
that there's life there and it's a
different life from Earth aha okay so
you're talking about the chirality or
handedness but what about the way it's
proteins are structured or the way that
you know the amino acids go together
that's really higher order stuff that's
hard to do without bringing a sample
back don't you agree
sure we want to answer all of our
questions we won't answer all of our
questions annoying sounds like you've
got some light for me rolling around
won't answer he wants to go okay we want
to answer all of our questions and more
complex questions will require more
complex instrumentation but we will be
able to answer some questions and if
there is light there we have a good
chance of determining that it's there
and determining that it's alien from
Earth one so well we could in principle
go pretty far down a logic tree now
eventually yes if you want to bring a
sample back to eventually the level of
sophistication we'd like to apply to
investigating a different type of light
is the state of the art and to do that
you need to bring the sample back but we
can make a lot of progress on the next
mission if we send it right in okay so
let me let me we you know this is our
last segment and I just wanted to open
it up even more if I could jump ahead
I'll ease please in the Saturn system
there's another tantalizing place which
is Titan Titan is considered kind of
believe it or not we used to think of
Venus's the sister planet to earth but
Titan is even more like Earth in many
respects than then Venus's it has
landforms that are like we have here on
earth because it's got a substance in
its atmosphere methane which acts like
water does here on earth and it rains
out of the sky can form clouds it can
carve channels and gullies and and so on
it can pond on the surface and in fact
it's doing that and the polar regions of
Titan we have found seas of liquid
methane
well laced with ethane so I mean think
of you know Lake Michigan brimming with
paint thinner or something like that you
know that's not too far off in the
future and we'll keep going the way
we're going right now
so so you know now I'm not a fan of
thinking that we have life in the seas
of Titan because or at least excuse me I
should say that we have a chance of
really
igniting it because it would be so
different than we have here on earth
because we know about earthly life but I
know Chris is a big fan of this idea so
I wanted to give Chris the opportunity
to elaborate on the possibility that we
could have life and Titan sees given
that the temperature there is so cold
and the kinetics are going to be so slow
and so on and then how we might go about
even recognizing life in the Titan C's
well that's a really good question and
it routes to what do we think like me
it's clear that life needs a liquid on
earth that liquid is walk or the only
other liquid that's widespread in the
solar system is the liquid methane and
ethane on type so could life use that
liquid now it's very different than
water but that doesn't mean that as a
bits my wife couldn't use it but it
would be so different we wouldn't really
know how to recognize it and that's
where we would the effect that life has
fun atmosphere as we talked about
earlier if there's life on Titan it
might be consuming hydrogen and we might
be able to detect that atmospheric
effect more readily than we could
actually detect the light form because
we don't even know what kind of
molecules to search for right it
certainly doesn't use them you know yeah
right it doesn't use amino acid so it's
it's going to be significantly different
it's just a challenge in the space
program it's a challenge to you know
like I said this is where the rubber
meets the road you have a design and
experiment you have to know what you're
going to measure and when you're looking
at at an environment that's alien to the
earth and life that may not even be
constructed like the earth that is no
common biochemicals it becomes very
challenging yes that was fascinating
that was great stuff great stuff I mean
uh I'm still fascinated by just a fact
of life living in a methane ocean that
that alone is kind of mind-boggling yeah
well you know you know they say was it
Rudyard Kipling that said travel is mind
expanding well you know planetary
exploration is mind blowing there you go
all right let's take a question pardon
me
I'm terribly sorry didn't through
Davenport and drew Davenport is writing
from wilmut Illinois here on planet
earth he actually put it that way oh
that's good we've known him yeah have
you ever found anything that you
couldn't identify where thought was
really strange
during a spectral analysis this is for
both of you actually because I'm sure
the spectral analysis is is part of both
your mission Oh major major well is
there anything that comes back were you
just like my that's that's odd
well drange I am NOT a spectral analyzer
myself but I remember in the early days
of the Cassini mission when we were
looking at the results of one of the
spectrometers onboard Cassini that had
scooped up material in the plume and
there were some signatures that they
couldn't make sense of and I think at
first in fact they did made a tentative
identification which did not turn out to
be correct and it turned out to be salt
rock I had they had not thought that
there would be salt and when they went
back and said okay maybe this is salt
and they went back and did the match it
was a great match so that's my little
anecdote Chris you must have one guess
it think it's something I can but along
the lines that I remember where we were
first going to Titan we thought it had a
global ocean we got there it didn't so
that we were often surprised I think we
have to keep that in mind we are dest
isn't what's out there are often wrong
right the only way to know is to go look
you know this brings up something that I
love to just remind people of in in
being explorers like we are you know
we're kind of our it's not our bodies
our minds and our emotions are on these
robotic spacecraft that we send across
the solar system and you know they find
things that are you know we say oh my
god that's so surprising we felt that
way about the Enceladus plume we felt
that way about the distribution of the
hydrocarbons on Titan we all felt that
way about Pluto
New Horizons got to Pluto oh my goodness
look at this these regions where you
have ice convection and these polygonal
features it's not so much that it's a
failure of knowledge it's a failure of
imagination
we understand physics pretty well in
chemistry we understand what happens at
various regimes physical regimes but
it's just that we don't spend an
infinite amount of time imagining all
the various permutations we might find
there and when we get there we end up
being surprised like take that Enceladus
geysers we new post Voyager this was
after the Voyager mission a couple of
years later a paper was written about
the possibility that we could have water
geysers on Enceladus right all right it
was suggested that these geysers they
might not have been called geysers but
they would be producing particles that
would go into orbit around Saturn to
produce the e ring in which Enceladus is
centrally embedded so that was the
connection so we had geysers on the
brain when we went to back to Enceladus
with Cassini and we even the imaging
team planned observations to look for
them and the first image that we have of
a plume coming off in celle dhis has the
word plume in the title of the
observation it was deliberately planned
to search for plumes right so we knew
what we possibly might find but nobody
took the time to imagine well okay so we
have geysers coming off in celle tiss
the gravity on Enceladus is only one
hundredth of the gravity here on the
earth so these things are going to be
enormous no one thought that right so we
get they there and we see this
incredible spectacle and it just it it
just reminded me of this that you know
we we always fail to imagine what we
might find so it and it's what it makes
it so thrilling you know just seeing
something for the first time it's just
it's mind-blowing that's pretty cool of
course it's cool excellent excellent
excellent stuff
all right let's actually Theron actually
actually Theron and coming to us on
Twitter at Astro Theron not to be
confused with
Charlize Theron maybe maybe that's a fan
of Shelley uh says ask this I really
don't understand this question and also
you guys don't have to help me given
similar environmental challenges ie
liquids behave the same is it possible
for exobiology to produce a species
similar to us I we have only about a
minute so you're saying given similar
biology is that the I similar chemistry
yes similar environmental yes should we
expect something similar to us yes in
other words is that are we more likely
to find something similar to us given
the similar situations or environmental
situations or you know I think actually
be using our imagination to look for
what you just said okay well using your
imagination for every permutation would
take quite a bit of time I think this is
a question that really devolves to this
what in the evolution of life what role
was played by basic physics and chemical
laws and what was played by serendipity
what was you know a meteor hit the earth
and destroyed the first experiment just
wiped out all life that was just getting
started
and then giving something else the
opportunity to evolve like you know the
dinosaurs being wiped out open up the
way for us so we only have seven
dinosaur seconds we're going to have to
wind down now Chris and Chuck thank you
for helping us out today
mark a pledge been listening to start
talk radio all-stars edition I've been
your all-star host Carolyn Porco until
next time this is Startalk
you
[Music]